that's the short URL to take you to the
repository for the tutorial today um and
then go ahead and clone that um if you
already cloned it before uh I
accidentally forgot to include the data
files in it until like 10 minutes ago so
thanks whoever tweeted that to me that
they were missing the data is now in the
repost so if you did clone it earlier in
the week maybe do a get PLL quick and
you'll get the data files that you'll
need uh there's some setup instructions
here BAS basically can uh CD into the
git repo sorry I'll leave this URL up
here a bit longer but CD in there and
then there's a cond environment. file if
you want to do cond EnV create um
that'll get you all the correct versions
of everything you need um if you're
using pip virtual in then there's some
instructions further down on the
page uh yeah basically using Python 3
and uh pandas latest pandas should be
pretty good okay give you a couple
minutes to get that sorry Wi-Fi is also
important if you don't have that
yet just uh while we're doing this if I
could get a survey of experience levels
uh who here has like first time
programming in Python maybe couple okay
great uh who here has never used the
Jupiter notebook be using that quite a
bit okay uh and then new to numpy pandas
that sort of stuff but have programmed
before okay uh and then you know more
experienced python Pi data stuff okay so
this is a introductory tutorial um it
starts out uh even more introductory and
then there's kind of a ramp about
halfway through so uh hopefully
hopefully it'll be good but definitely
do stop me at any time if you have any
questions um it's meant to be
interactive so uh please do stop got me
I encourage you to work through the
examples as I go through them up here uh
we can go through them them together and
then throughout the notebooks there's
some exercises that um I'll have you do
if you
want okay uh anyone not able to clone
this repo
yet unable to clone it at the very least
uh Wi-Fi okay do these instructions make
sense you have to go through UIC guest
first and then put in one of those
username p
passwords um of people who are able to
clone it were you able to get the
environment set up see a few heads Yeah
question
or yeah uh so environment uh cond and uh
virt P pip whatever virtual in um
they're basically ways of isolating uh a
set of packages uh so that you can have
multiple versions of like pandas
installed on your computer without them
conflicting with each other
so I just included this so that we we
don't have any dependency issues uh
because pandas is known to change their
API from time to
time any other
issues I think um
okay people who weren't able to clone it
have you succeeded getting on Wi-Fi okay
okay maybe give like one more minute and
then we'll get into the first
notebook um for people who have
successfully done that um but I haven't
used Jupiter before so this is the
repository if you CD into the Panda's
head to tail and then um make sure to
activate your environment so I think
it's like Source activate uh Panda's
head to tail or activate
phtt or if you're on Windows I think
it's just activate um make sure you're
in the right environment and then you
can start up the notebook server with
jupyter notebook and then we can get
into the first notebook
any issues on
that just raise your
hand yeah having
troubles look
stuck gotcha is git get slow GitHub slow
I I guess GitHub will throttle if too
many people from the same network try
and download the same thing but
hopefully it'll finish up um the first
uh so the first notebook I'm going to
get into that now uh it's uh basically
me just laying out the basics so not too
interactive so as that downloads
finishing you shouldn't be missing out
on anything really um so I think we'll
get into it now and if you are still
having trouble raise your hand maybe
Greg or someone will help you out uh get
you going
so okay yeah you having troubles
sir uh
3.5 um although any version of Python 3
should work python 2 might work I didn't
test it though but if you're using cond
it'll install python as well uh the
correct version of
python
okay all right uh let's get into it then
so first notebook is uh very
introductory so if you haven't used
jupyter notebooks before they're just
you know interactive Computing
environment in the browser um tied to a
kernel in this case python to actually
execute your code so uh there's two
modes basically there's an edit mode and
a command mode you start out in command
to actually edit files to you know edit
sorry edit cells code you'll hit enter
to go into the cell um you can hit
escape to go back into uh command mode
to move around with j and k and then to
actually execute a cell you'll hit shift
enter so that's how you'd be doing for
the most part is just shift enter
throughout and then writing your code in
edit mode okay um so the the pandas is
built on top of numpy that's like the
core IND dimensional array Library used
in Python um so it's good to know some
of those numpy isms that leak up into
pandas um so the heart of numpy is the
IND dimensional array this is a
container data container like list
except their numpy arrays are typed so
they all have a type in this case we
have a d type of in6 C 4 and they're
also fixed width or fixed length they
have a shape um and you're not going to
be like app pending onto them they're
fixed length so numpy provides quite a
few types you can look through the
documentation have a look at those um I
should how's the font size in the back
can everyone see
it okay um so numpy provides all these
types um with respect to the type system
the biggest things to keep in mind are
that missing values um pandas uses Nan
not a number to represent missing values
we'll see this a lot um but Nan is a
float so if you have a column of
integers and one Nan it's going to cast
your column of integers to floats which
is unfortunate and uh it's going to be
fixed eventually it's a big problem um
and then numpy arrays also have a a
single dtype for the entire array so
this is numpy arrays it just has one
dtype so you can't have like a column of
integers and a column of floats and a
column of strings it's one D type for
the entire thing pandas solves that
problem and then object D type is the
fallback like python objects and you
want to avoid that if you
can okay one of the um important
Concepts behind numpy is vectorization
so this is what lets numpy go fast one
of the things um basically if you have
two arrays same shape here um
vectorization the idea is to basically
let numpy do the work of actually like
iterating through these pairs if we want
to add these two together in Python we
would you know write out the for Loop ex
explicit explicitly and then add each
pair together with numpy it's just X
Plus y so that's vectorization um it's
you know it's going to be faster for
sure just like in numpy and in pandas
and it's also sometimes more convenient
way of writing things sometimes it can
be harder though um and then the last
numpy thing we'll talk about is
broadcasting so this uh this is what
lets you do operations between arrays of
different shapes so you can think of if
we have X this
a range okay from zero to four uh you
can think of a scalar one as like a Zero
Dimensional array um you don't have to
worry about reshaping that one to be the
same shape as X to do operations same
thing here with y y is uh 2 by5 and you
can do operations between arrays and
scalars no problem and as long as the
shapes of the two arrays are conformable
so basically what that means is that the
last Dimension matches you can do
operations between arrays so of any
Dimension as long as that last Dimension
matches numpy will take care of the
broadcasting and it basically just does
what you would expect it to do okay
without that you have to do all this
like reshaping and repetition stuff so
that's no fun okay so that's numpy in
like five minutes uh we uh we're going
to do a very brief overview of the
Panda's data structures um but I don't
like uh you know very I I don't like I
I'd much rather do practical examples so
that's how we we'll be doing the
majority of the learning here um but
before we get there just to give a high
level over overview of what Panda solves
uh first of all labeled arrays if you
saw up here these nonp arrays they're
just arrays um but most of the time the
data I work with have labels associated
with them um so there we'll be seeing
that quite a bit um like I mentioned
before P numpy arrays are homogeneous
there's just a single D type for the
entire array pandas data frames are
heterogenous so you can have multiple
data types in your table um it has
better missing handling different I'd
say pandas is more practical about
missing values are gonna happen they're
going to be in your data set and pandas
has the tools for dealing with those and
then bunch of convenient methods we'll
see uh all of
those data structures are like where
every tutorial starts right so we had to
follow suit um the main data structure
you'll be working with is the data frame
this is like a t tabular uh
two-dimensional uh inmemory table and
you know the way they work basically is
you've got the data in in the middle of
your data frame um and then you have
some column labels and you have some row
labels so these row labels are uh very
important um they come up in a lot of
things like alignment and then the first
thing we'll talk about here indexing so
selecting subsets to the data so if you
want to select a column you'll use the
regular python get item square brackets
and then just pass in the column label
that you want to select so we can select
the column a um if you want to select
multiple columns at once you can pass in
a list of columns calls here is a list
of columns and we select those
two for rowwise selection you'll use l
so dolo says uh give me the row labels
lowercase a and lowercase
B and then you you can do ranges and
stuff like that just like with regular
python list slicing you can do ranges as
well
yeah uh they can be anything yeah uh
yeah whatever you
have by default they are going to be
integers uh zero through length of the
data frame but I explicitly passed in
this ABC here and um yeah one sec any
other questions so
far okay um so yeah that L is how you'll
be doing that uh the other way of
selecting is by position so that was by
label uh oftentimes it's convenient to
select by position too like say if you
wanted the first two rows you'll use do
IO so pass in the integers zero and one
uh grab those first two rows by position
you can also do slicing and stuff on
that and you can mix these together
right so the basic the more general rule
is L and then row labels comma column
labels same thing with that IO it would
be row positions comma column
positions and you can mix these all
together but this is probably like the
most important summary here is you use
regular python get item square brackets
for selecting columns use lope row
labels comma column labels for selection
by position and then IO for or sorry mix
that up uh this is for by label based
and then IO for position based
indexing okay so that's data frames very
briefly series are like the
one-dimensional analog of data frames a
data frame is a container for series uh
you saw them before they're what you get
back when you slice a single
column notice that they have their index
here though they still keep the row
labels um you can get it in a lot of
ways square brackets um p window
attaches these uh column names as
attributes on the data frame so you can
do DFA very convenient um you just have
to be careful not to Shadow a data frame
method so mean is a method on data frame
so if you do DF do mean you'll get the
method not the
column if you have that shadowing then
you need to use the square
brackets okay um I think we'll skip that
the last one is indexes uh so these are
the row labels and column labels they're
actually this other data container
called an index um so they're kind of
peculiar to pandas they're um R has roow
labels but not in the same way that
pandas uses their roow labels with
indexes so um indexes can be whatever
you want there specialized types like
datetime index indices if you have uh
datetime data float 64 categorical index
um so we'll be seeing those throughout
the tutorial but for now just know that
indexes are your container for row
labels and they're they're object in
their own right okay they're usually
good to have uh sometimes they can get
in the way but uh more often than not
they're they're really
useful okay questions on
that next notebook will be more
interactive that's just setting the
stage
yeah indexes are
unfortunately we allow duplicates in the
indexes they that can cause a lot of
issues um but sometimes you need it so
uh in general I would say you want to
have a unique index and you can always
check that with uh like DF index. is
unique um yeah in general you want to
have unique Ro
labels
okay all right um I should also say
there's a h getter channel here um so if
you're having any troubles uh if you
just click on this link in the main
GitHub repo the will open up a chat page
thing where you can like post questions
or whatever solutions to your
examples all righty um so if you want to
jump into the second notebook
operations was ever unable to get it
cloned
eventually all righty so the first half
of this is more just talking and then
we'll get into some actual exercises and
some real examples
so data frame in series like numpy
arrays they support vectorized
operations um one of these is uun so
this is another numpy thing uh stands
for Universal function and U funks
operate on any Dimension array so it's
it's because they operate element wise
basically they don't need any other
information they just go through element
by element applying their operation so
things like addition is a uunk
exponentiation log these are all U funks
and they all work just fine on data
frames just like they would on a numpy
array um these are going to be much
faster than iterating over your data
frame you almost never want to iterate
over your data frame it'll be a lot
slower last one um alignment so this is
uh something it takes some time to get
used to but um it's extremely convenient
when you're working with data sets um
with where your data is spread across
multiple data frames so anytime you do a
binary operation between two data frames
like or data frame in a series uh like
addition say um pandas is going to first
align the two data frames and then do
the operation so in this case and sorry
it aligns by labels by index and column
labels so for this one they have the
same labels df1 and df2 have the same
labels so when we go and do the
operation it just does exactly what
you'd expect right same labels um we'll
make a new df2 notice that the we swap
the first two rows of df2 here so the
index is now
2011 um we can do df1 plus df2 and we
get the aligned by label version so this
is the identical result to above that's
because before doing the addition pandas
first aligned by label it said okay
these are the same index but in a
different order I'm going to reorder it
it to the df1 version and then do the
operation so this can be extremely
convenient because if you get deep into
an analysis and you're just using like
numpy arrays it's on you as the
programmer to know that the row in this
one matches with the row in this other
one which can be tricky when you're
doing like group eyes and stuff like
that Panda's much easier to let pandas
manage that with the index
labels um and then you can have
different index indices entirely so df3
now has some extra rows and extra column
um when you go to do that pandas will
introduce missing values Nan so when it
aligns it doesn't just reorder it'll say
it'll take the union of the indices
it'll note that df1 didn't know about
Row three or four or column C so it
introduces nans there and then Nan plus
anything is going to be Nan so you get
nans in the
output okay any questions on
that
yeah
um so pandas does it automatically so
you don't really have the option to not
align the
two which uh yeah there might be cases
where you don't want that but I'm
struggling to think of one typically
you'll want
alignment okay so that is it for me just
standing up here talking at you um we're
getting to our first real application
and everything from here out will be
actual real data um first one we'll be
looking at some time series data um does
this uh next cell work for everyone
everyone has all the Imports hopefully
working okay um so before um I grabbed
some data from Fred the Federal Reserve
economic database um I grabb data on GDP
gross domestic product uh CPI which is a
measure of inflation and uh a recession
indicator using the data reader package
pandas data reader and then you all
should have this um data here uh does
anyone not have the data if you had an
old clone before I pushed the data might
need to redo
that yeah having
trouble Greg do you think you good
thanks um okay Greg's gonna come help
you
out okay everyone else good though so we
can look at the first few rows here um
and we can see that each one of these is
the same thing basically it has date uh
on the first kind of cell column there
and then the actual values this case GDP
as a second column so pandas uh most of
the time you're not actually
constructing these data frames by hand
you'll be typically reading them in from
a data source so pandas has a whole
bunch of uh read underscore methods so
you can read from clipboard CSV Excel a
ton of different options there um read
tsv is extremely power powerful uh last
I look it has like 55 parameters which
is crazy and awesome uh it can handle a
lot of different badly formed csvs um so
these ones are thankfully not too bad um
we'll just use the index call equal date
so this says use that First Column as
the row labels and then parse parse that
First Column as date
times uh then we can look at gdp. head
that gives the first five rows
yeah squeeze uh sorry that uh turns it
into a series so if I just had
this if you have a um this is a data
frame do you see the difference in the
representations here this is a data
frame and it uses the HTML pretty
rendering um when I squeeze it this is
now a series and it's a yeah it's a
series so if you have a onedimensional
data frame squeeze will turn it down
into a
series okay
this since this is really onedimensional
yeah yeah so this is a the question was
what does this question mark do this is
a Jupiter notebook or IPython thing yeah
Jupiter in general um you can
it'll basically look up the help the doc
string and then bring it up in this
pager so that is specific to Jupiter not
valid
python okay uh so we can look at the
first five rows with head last five rows
with tail uh CPI again inflation and
then the recession
indicator so there are a ton of
different useful methods on data frames
uh we'll be using mean later in a second
so I wanted to show you that basically
what this does is it just takes the
average of in this case we have the
series so it's just a one column if you
have a data frame it'll do each column
independently taking the mean of each
there a bunch of plotting methods we're
just going to kind of skip over this but
make sure to execute the cells um I only
included this to get the nice pretty re
recession bar indicators there um this
is just some mat plot Li stuff for the
most
part all right first exercise um your
your task is to convert CPI to be base
2009 so CPI is an index Consumer Price
Index uh which basically means it
doesn't have any units the what BLS I
think calculates it um and they just
chose some year or they chose 1982 to
1984 to be the index which basically
means they took the raw values for the
entire series and divided by the average
over 1982 to
1984 okay uh let's say that we wanted to
convert that to be base 2009 so um what
we need to do is Select just 2009 just
the values for 2009 out of CPI so we
have CPI here you want to select just
the values for 2009 using those indexing
things that I talked about in the last
notebook and then take the average of
that and then divide the entire series
by whatever that average is okay so for
each of these exercises uh I've left you
some room here so you can go ahead and
work on it and then when you think
you've got it or if you get stuck you
can execute this uh Magic this percent
load magic another Jupiter specific
thing um and that'll load the solution
for you so want you take like 30 seconds
a minute to try and do this uh read
through this this will help you out
there's a little bit of special uh
indexing magic for for datetime indices
when you have dates in your index makes
s a little easier just take a minute or
so to work on
that and then I think there's a followup
exercise if you want to calculate real
GDP based on that last
step
yeah
you're
up
okay um
so to get the uh average or to select
the values for 2009 we'll use. L right
we're doing row label selection pandas
has this nice Syntax for selecting
subsets of Time series you can just use
partial string indexing um this is
really nice because you can do like if I
just want the first month right you can
just pass that in so we'll select the
entire year we'll use mean to get the
average for that and then we'll say CPI
09 is going to be equal to that entire
series CPI divided by that and then
times 100 to make
it uh centered at 100
okay any questions on
that if you were doing this you have
to execute the cell once to have the
solution pop up then execute it again to
actually run the cell
so that is uh cp9 and if you uh yeah
plot it it looks identical pretty much
only the 100 is now here at 2009 um if
you wanted to try and calculate re real
GDP so real GDP is nominal GDP not
inflation adjusted divided by CPI
09 and if you go to plot this
rgdp you'll notice um you get a blank
plot and that's because if you look at
real
GDP it's got a real GDP got a bunch of
missing values basically so Panda's um
when we did that operation Panda's
aligned by the uh indices of the two uh
GDP is quarterly and CPI is monthly so
we've got all these missing values
pandas has some methods to like Drop
missing values fill missing values we'll
just drop these and then plot it um so
now we actually get our
line
so we fill an a drop an a um okay this
is going into that last step we did um
if you didn't have alignment you would
end up writing something like this we'll
see this what this is doing uh in the
next notebook but basically you're
saying okay manually filtering down to
just the common rows right so where
index. Monon is divisible by three so we
get the same frequency on CPI and then
they start at different times and end at
different times you have to make sure
those align too so you know this is what
you'd do if you didn't have alignment
but since we do have alignment it's as
simple as just doing the
division um most pandas methods are um
yeah most pandas methods are they don't
mutate in place pretty much every method
I think so when you do real gdp. drop a
it'll return a new series and real GDP
will still have the missing values in it
so you'll need to assign that output of
that drop and a to a new data frame or a
data frame with the same name and then
you can get your result okay uh make
plots um there's an ex exercise here if
you want to go back later you can try
and recreate this uh this graph from
calculated risk um Panda's you know it's
like five lines or so to get that um did
I include the solutions whoops um that
wasn't supposed to be in there anyway
you can uh maybe just look at this and
then try and do it on yourself and then
compare against the included Solutions
sorry about that um but we will move on
to the third notebook unless there are
any questions on operations first I
don't know why it does
that so the third notebook is indexing
if you want to go ahead and get that
opened
up indexing is like I don't know it's
it's probably one of the most
complicated things in pandas just
because it tries to do so much um if you
think about list right you can index by
location and that's it you just pass in
the number um so pandas wants to support
location with the io uh you can like
with dictionaries you can uh index by
key and Panda supports that
withl um numpy arrays if you're familiar
with those you'll do a lot of Boolean
indexing so Panda supports that as well
um unlike lists or dictionary or at
least dictionaries Panda supports
looking up by multiple items by arrays
of items not just single Keys um you can
also pass in slices ranges things like
that um and pandas also has this notion
of hierarchical indexing where you have
multiple levels in your index so
indexing pandas does a lot to help make
selecting data easy um it just makes
things complicated sometimes uh so the
data set we'll be working with here is
from this beer advocate.com data set of
reviews uh the raw data that I grabbed
um I've only included a subset so the
raw data's like got all this it's kind
of weird format um and I've included
this just because it's like one of my
favorite features of pandas is that it's
in Python so you get access to Python's
great capabilities for processing uh
data like this so um you know this is a
review uh here and then there's a blank
line and then the second review starts
so to get that into a form ready for a
data frame you'll be using like the
regular python libraries uh and then
once it's in a tabular shape you can
read it into a data frame so the data
set was also pretty large it didn't fit
in memory so the great thing about
python python 3 specifically is that
everything is lazy so you can go through
and you know open up a file that doesn't
actually fit in memory you can you know
read in these reviews but we haven't
actually done anything yet since
everything here is lazy so Partition by
comes from tools and all this is doing
make this tad smaller is looking for
those blank lines to separate the
reviews splitting on those and then
filtering out those lines that are just
blank but we haven't actually done any
work yet right this is all lazy um this
map in Python 3 is lazy so we can use as
format reviews all that's doing is going
from basically this to a dictionary
where these are the keys and then these
are the values so that's all this is
doing uh you know then we can partition
it into chunks of a thousand but we
still haven't read anything into memory
right you see the pattern here uh and
then only now when we start to iterate
over the reviews we get chunks of
100,000 reviews at a time okay and these
fit in memory we can process them all we
can read them into a data frame using
this little function I wrote here and
then we can write that out to disk okay
so that's like one of the best things
about pandas is written in Python you
have access to all these other great
libraries um this data set was also like
just random the row ordering was random
I wanted to get a sub slice of time so
to do that um I basically took like
between the 50th and 60th percentile
here um but again it didn't fit in
memory so using dask which is a project
built on top of numpy and pandos and
other libraries um you're able to
operate on data frames that don't fit in
memory and I think Skipper is giving a
little little introduction to that uh
this afternoon so maybe check out dask
if you're curious about working with
larger than memory data sets it's a
really nice Library um okay so the
subset I included um does fit in memory
so you can read in uh that data frame in
the cell uh we got another option here
compression so pandas can read
compressed files um and we can take a
look at the data we have data some data
about the beer itself made a data about
the beer and then the reviewer wres it
on a few different scales and then
there's some metadata about the
reviewer
okay Boolean indexing I mentioned this
before so this is like a wear wear
clause in SQL so give me the rows where
the ABV is less than five and the way
you'll write that is either by passing
it into G item so you pass in this
Boolean series into get
item or you can pass itops uh sorry pass
it into
Lo and that as the row indexer so filter
it down to these rows where ABV is less
than five and then just give me these uh
columns you can mix and match things
here uh right so conditions can just be
joined up with the and or the or
operators here bitwise and bitwise or
the only thing you have to be careful
about is the order of operations here so
python considers uh greater than less
than equal to have higher precedence
than the bitwise and an or so this is
true even though it shouldn't be right
shouldn't uh to fix that you'll do the
the parenthesis so if you don't have
this like a super common error if you
didn't have these first set of
parentheses around this and you'd get a
very confusing message about doing these
bitwise and not supported so if you run
into this it's probably because you're
missing
parenthesis okay so for our first
exercise here um we want to find the
rows where the beer style contains
IPA um so to do this you'll need to use
one method we haven't seen before um and
that's this uh do stir and I haven't
given away the answer but there's a
method in this little name space pandas
does this with a few different things
like stir and date times um if you have
a column that is of string types you'll
have this do stir namespace on here and
you can do things like stir.
capitalize um so these largely um follow
the python uh python string Methods for
the most
part so you'll use one of these methods
to get the that Boolean mask of rows
that contain the string
IPA and then you can pass that into the
indexer so take like a minute or so to
work on that select just the rows where
the beer style contains IPA and then you
can follow that up with the next
exercise where you find rows where the
beer style is exactly American IPA or
exactly
pser so maybe a minute to work on those
two questions on Boolean
indexing or
anything okay
so for this one hopefully you found
the stir. contains method so look for
rows that contain
IPA and then that's going to be a
Boolean
mask which we can pass into get
item okay questions on that
one the second one um you'll
be finding the ones that
contain uh American IPA or
pilsner so we use regular equal equal
here for American
IPA and then or with the pipe DF beer
style equal equal
pilsner okay so that's going to be
another Boolean array which you can pass
to get
item questions on those two
yeah uh which
find uh stir. find I'm assuming yeah so
the question was what is DF beer
Style Beer style. s.find so these are
going to be um let's say these are
either string Methods or reg regular
expression methods so these are like the
re. find and readind all from the rigex
library again if you questions you can
pull that
up
okay um so Isen is another way of
basically so these next couple sections
I say higher level
um you know uh Boolean indexing is
useful because so many different methods
produce arrays of booleans so it's going
to there basically a lot of ways to
filter down your data just to the exact
way you need so if you wanted to redo
that last example maybe you had like 10
different kinds of beer Styles you
wouldn't want to write out all of these
ores right um it'd be easier to use
something like Isen so it's like a where
beer style is in American IPA or
pilsner so that's uh bit more useful if
you have a bunch of different things
you're trying to filter down so in this
case we'll look at um like the top
reviews uh the beers with the most
number of reviews using this value
counts so what that does is uh it'll
return a copy paste this out it'll
return a series where the keys are the
Brewer IDs or sorry the index labels are
the Brewer IDs and then the values in
the series are the actual counts so the
number of time that beer was reviewed so
that's what value counts is doing so we
did that for the Brewer IDs and the beer
IDs um and now you can filter it down
saying okay give me the rows where
Brewer ID is in Brewer IDs the top 10
Brewer IDs and where beer ID is in the
top 10 beer IDs so we get back this
two-dimensional array so this one was in
the top 10 Brewer
IDs if you just pass this into get item
you'll probably get something you didn't
expect or probably don't want and so
two-dimensional you know Boolean
indexing usually isn't what you want
usually you want to uh collapse that
two-dimensional array of booleans down
into a one-dimensional series first um
with either saying give me the rows
where both the uh Brewer ID is in the
top 10 and the be idas in the top 10 so
you do that with thisall
operation so what that does is collapses
it across the columns and then only
gives the you know is true where both
were true and is false where either is
false or you could use the any reduction
method and this will give you this row
will be true where either was true so
again anything that returns a Boolean
array is potentially an
indexer um so for this one we'll see
another example that um find the rows
where the RS are all at least
four so you'll need to be uh select
those reviews and then use one of those
collapse those reduction methods and
you're all to collapse that down to a
single uh
Dimension and then pass that into get
item and you can also work on the next
exercise we'll give a couple minutes for
these select the rows where the average
is at least
four just say again just at a high level
we're getting these Boolean arrays and
collapsing them down to a single level
so there's a bunch of reduction methods
that can be used
here
so for this first one selecting where
first all we have DF uh review
calls just these rows uh where these
rows are all at least four so we can
say you know is each of these elements
greater than four this give us back that
you know four columns and then or five
uh and then we want to do do all of one
or do all of columns to collapse that so
reduction methods in general the way to
remember it is it you know is it zero or
one basically you pass in the column
that you or sorry the dimension that you
want to remove so this will remove the
column's
dimension and then you can use that as
the
indexer for the second exercise there uh
where the average of the uh reviews is
at least four so again first of all you
can say uh DF of review
calls
mean and again columns so take the mean
along the First
Dimension and this gives us the series
the average for that row greater than
four so now we have a Boolean mask and
that we can pass into get
item okay questions on those
two here again the high level thing to
remember is anything that returns a
Boolean array can be a Boolean
indexer
okay all right um hierarchical indexing
so this is uh getting into one of the
more complicated things um this set
index method will take a column or a
list of columns and move them down into
the index so this is a multi-index
now and these can be useful for like
keeping metadata out of your data frame
um just so like it doesn't get mixed up
in operations or anything like that it's
also Ed for useful for aligning things
that maybe apply to like the profile
name you have like a series of just
profile names and some data with that um
and then being able to join that to this
uh kind of higher dimensional thing uh
with for the reviews table so
multi-indices are useful but again they
can be complicated usually you want to
sort them so you can use the sort index
method um and say we wanted to select
the top reviewers by label so we get the
top reviewers using just the value
counts again selecting the index so
these are the profiles with the most
reviews and the way this works is you'll
pass in the uh the labels that you want
to select so this is a list or array of
labels and then use the regular python
colon for representing the rest so numpy
uses this as well so select the rest of
the columns so all of these columns
basically or sorry all of these uh from
this uh level of the
multi-index and again uh you know you
have to be careful with the syntax if
you wanted to look up like a single one
um like this this is invalid syntax
because you can't put the colon in these
inside these parentheses you can only
use colon in certain places so pandas
provides this index slice kind of helper
thing to generate the correct slice that
you need so we can select just the top
reviewers for be ID 99 and
anytime so this can be quite useful and
we'll see it in the next section on
groupi um I think we'll skip over the
rest of this you can read through it if
you run into chain indexing problems but
uh just for time we'll jump into the
fourth notebook group I and
reshaping
again and we're using the same data set
there
so just as a kind of example of what's
possible you can say okay give me the
reviews all right the count of each
reviews kind of group by kind uh you
know review appearance Aroma overall is
using Seaborn and this is kind of common
you'll be using things like stack and
unstack um and melts uh to be basically
getting your data into the correct form
for whatever API is expecting it so
count plot kind of wants this long form
of Stack data which we'll see in a
second um but being able to transition
between wide and long to reshape your
data is pretty important to work with
all the different apis that you'll be
coming into contact with um so group I I
think you know it's pretty important
maybe I don't need to explain why but
just being able to uh calculate things
on subsets of your data at a time um
independent from the rest is uh fairly
common operation and the way pandas
likes to talk about is a three-stage
thing where you split your table into
groups by some method um you apply some
you apply some function to each of the
groups independently and then you
combine the results
somehow so the first step the split
looks like DF dog Group by and then
grouper where grouper can be like a
series or a column label um a function
to operate on the index dictionary
levels so lots of options there we'll
see a few of those um so we'll in this
case we'll just say DF Group by beer
style so we'll be operating on each beer
style
independently this gr this group by
object hasn't actually really done
anything yet it's just recording some
information about which rows go with
which group basically and then the last
two steps um you can say Okay apply the
mean function and this egg. egg is
saying aggregate that's kind of hinting
how it should be combined pandas handles
that combination step the to combine
everything back
together and this with this so basically
egg is saying give me one row per
group
okay so you can you know do a lot of
things you can slice this group by
object so if we just want are interested
in the review columns so we can select
those and then aggregate them again get
the dot attribute access looks works
just like on the series so you can say
gr if you just want to look at ABV and
then finally the shortest way to write
it is gr. ABV do mean so these methods
are also attached to uh to the data
frame or sorry the group by
object okay so first exercise here um
find the beer styles with the greatest
variance or standard deviation in
ABV so you'll need to first of all
calculate that so you can use either STD
or V to get the standard deviation and
then sort values to sort the
values think uh 30 seconds or so on that
questions on Group
by makes
sense
I said it took us a while to come up
with this name and that's not actually a
joke it really did take us a while to
come up with sort
values naming things is
hard
so getting the standard deviation or you
could use variance it'll be the same
outcome um and then sort
values um and we'll want it doesn't
matter but we say ascending equal false
to have largest to smallest so these are
the reviews with the most variance
there questions on
that
yeah yeah so the question was what was
ABV um that's a column in the data frame
ABV uh alcohol same alcohol by volume or
something I don't know it's measur the
alcohol content um and so just like on
Series where you can do DF do ABV you
can also do that on Group by objects so
DF Group by beer Style
ABV right so this is just a series Group
by
object by volume is it okay I'll call by
volume good to
know uh
okay um so yeah this next section is
kind of getting down into the weeds but
there's like a ton of combinations for
group IES extremely flexible um for you
know what you should expect for the
output shape it kind of depends on a few
things so the grouper we just Group by a
single column but you can also Group by
multiple columns and if you have
multiple columns you'll get back a
multi-index so we'll see that in a
second uh the thing being operated on
the group E you might say is going to
control the the values in the data frame
so it's either going to be a single
column if you're operating on a single
column or sorry it'll be a single column
if you have a uh single aggregation and
multiple columns if you have uh multiple
aggregations which is the next step
we've only seen a single aggre AG
aggregation so far but you can also
apply multiple aggregation functions at
the same time so in this case right we
have a single uh thing that we're groupy
right single groupy and then againg with
mean you can also you use functions like
np. STD anything that returns a single
value uh counts so things like that so
we get back at data frame here with a
single Index right since we still are
just using that one group by beer Style
um and we can you know just go through
all these it might be more useful to
look back later but uh you know
selecting multiple columns single
aggregation gives us back a data frame
um multiple aggregations on multiple
columns so this will return a data frame
with a hierarchical index in the
columns everyone see that so it applies
you know it looks at just first of all
the review appearance applies all three
egg funks and then goes the next column
applies all three egg funks so these can
be a bit awkward to work with so
typically I'll use stack to move one of
these levels down into the index so in
this case we move this topmost level
from columns down to the index with
stack and that level equals zero is
saying take the outermost
column so now the the beer style or
sorry the the review appearance Aroma
whatever is now a uh level in the
multi-index in the row
labels um if you have multi-index it's
also often times useful to group by say
one of those levels so now we can say
Group by this level just this outermost
beer style
level and looking just at the mean
column we can select the Min and the max
so now we have the Min and the
max average review by beer style okay so
you can do a lot of complicated things
there yeah
question sure um so this is is saying
maybe it be easier if I wrote it like um
I'm going to collect this thing first uh
okay so you have this
multi-dimensional thing in the
columns and we can either move the
outermost level or the inner level so uh
if we do multi.
stack this is GNA so in general stack
moves everything down um I thought oh by
default it's just
the innermost level okay uh sorry I was
mistaken there um so stack will move
down one of the columns or one of the
levels of the multi-index in the columns
down into the index so we want the
outermost level which is zero you can
also do one you can also do negative
indexing so the innermost level things
like that but what it's
yeah um the default would be minus one
which is the innermost level which
happens to be one in this case since
there's two levels right right that's
the
same but yeah in general stack is moving
things from the columns down into the
index and if you do stack again it'll
keep
going any other questions that's it like
yeah so that stuff I don't expect to
remember all that because there's so
many different options um but yeah
there's a lot of flexibility a lot of
power
there um okay exercise here um
relationship between the review length
and the average review
overall so again split this up first
thing you need is a grouper right before
we were just grouping by beer style now
we're grouping by something else so we
need to calculate that series that we
need to group by which in this case is
the length the Len of each
row Group by that
series select just review overall take
the mean and then plot
that you might want to use this style
equal K dot to get a reasonable looking
plot let's take a minute or so on that
if you have any questions let me
know you'll kind of see this pandas
likes to encourage small methods each
one that does you know a particular
thing and then you can chain these small
methods together to get your actual
answer
just so you're not entirely lost before
we were doing DF that group by beer
style you can also pass in a series
which is what you'll be doing in this
case so we don't have this series yet
this is what you're going to pass into
group I and you need to calculate
that
so the first step getting that length we
have the full text of the review and vf.
text we'll look ater and do the doer.
Len method so that calculates the length
of each
string uh length of each review
so that's the thing we're going to group
by and then we will take just review
overall and then calculate the mean so
this is the average review overall
grouped by the length of the
reviews and again you can plot that with
uh style equal K
Dot and get your plot so you know it's
useful to be able to build these up um
as you go and you can break this out
like this is a lot of logic right in the
middle of the function call it's a bit
complicated but you could break this out
into a separate step if you
wanted questions on
that I think we'll skip over the next
exercise it's basically the same thing
um these stir methods are flexible so
you can Group by like regular
Expressions things like that um I think
we'll skip over that though um maybe
skip this one as
well uh also going to skip this like
yeah there's a lot of stuff in here um
don't quite have time to get to but you
can do some pretty pretty impressive
things pretty succinctly I think um so
transform is a so I should say you know
we have this data frame. groupi um and
then we've only looked at egg so far um
that's kind of like one of the three
kinds of things um trans oh one of the
three kinds of ways you can um operate
on a group by objects so egg returns one
row per result transform will return an
identically shaped output as the input
and then apply you can just do whatever
you want it's extremely flexible um so
for transform this is useful like if you
wanted to like do a recommendation
system or something maybe you want to
kind of uh demean everyone's reviews by
their own personal reviews so you know
we can do that with the entire data
frame by passing in using this function
right and taking the review minus the
average so this demeans the entire
series of review
overall you can apply that function to
each group with the transform method um
this is a long line I'm GNA break this
up quick uh so select uh just review
overall grouping by profile name so each
individual selecting just review overall
and then transforming according to that
dmean function and then the output of
this will be identical to the input
shape so you can just select uh you can
just put it back into the as a new
column in
DF so you know even though this first
review was the same for these two people
um this one was a lot more um I guess
meaningful this 4.5 is a lot more higher
than this person's 4.5 because um his I
guess tend to be higher on average than
the first person's so transform is
useful if you want to do group-wise
operations but get back a same shaped
object finally apply we'll talk about in
the next
notebook time series um has some special
methods uh Group by like methods on them
so this is a data set of flights um
and we can get like the departure time
okay doing do value counts is that like
a second or minute frequency which maybe
Isn't So useful you can plot it but you
know who really cares how many left at
this exact minute um so in that case
maybe we want to resample to a different
frequency um so this resampler is kind
of like a group by object hasn't really
done anything yet um we just changed the
API so um yeah uh now it's like this
group by object you can this
warning which you can do methods on like
mean and then you can plot it so this is
now resampled to an hourly frequency you
could also write this as a group by like
by going through and calculating the
hour attribute of each of those rows but
it's much simpler to just use this
resample
syntax so again that maybe not too
useful you can also do multiples of
hours so like 3 H so resample to three
hours aggregate so for each three hour B
select the mean um you can do different
aggregations so we can resample to daily
and take the sum pretty flexible
here there's also these rolling objects
which will in a similar way it'll give
you a a group I like object this rolling
of seven again hasn't done
anything but you can do aggregations on
it mean and plot it okay so group I is
you know just for en things and then for
like time series stuff you can use do
resample is usually what you
want okay any questions on that I know
we're going fast I wanted to get to the
next notebook though I think we have
like 25 minutes
left uh seven is uh seven well so this
happened to be daily
data um daily right is going to have one
row per
day and then that
says uh take a rolling a seven whatever
period rolling window so seven day in
this
case any other
questions okay this will be the last
notebook I think the most important
perhaps so if you want to get that
opened
up it's going be talking about uh tidy
data which is a way
of well it's two things it's a way of
structuring your data it's also a way of
kind of thinking about how to do data
analysis uh the way Hadley Wickham who's
a author of a lot of our packages likes
to describe it is um structuring data
sets to facilitate analysis that yeah
that's a very succinct way of putting it
um the rules for a tidy day set that
we'll be concerned with are each
variable should form a column colum and
each observation should form a row um so
we'll see an example of this next uh I
grabbed some data from this website it's
just got uh using the panda read HTML so
this will do like basic scraping of
tables um if it's like really badly
formatted HTML then you might have to
use something like beautiful soup but um
read HTML will do
okay and the data set itself is kind of
messy there's like these random columns
that don't have names there's these rows
each month kind of gets its like header
row inside the table so um it's kind of
messy um but the question this stack
Overflow person was asking you know he
had this data set and he was asking okay
um how many days of rest did each team
get between each
game so question do we have a tidy data
set can we answer that question with a
data set that looks like this what do
you
think would I be asking you yeah
Greg no we do not have a tidy data set
what would a tidy data set look like to
answer this question what do we need
what is our what are our
rows each team's games yeah yeah exactly
so that those are the two components
there there's going to be
a team
and a game so those two pairs together
game being like the date that's what we
can use to calculate the days of rest
between free for each team which we
don't have right here we have a date and
then we have two teams so our team is
spread across two
columns okay so before we can even get
to the tidying part we just have some
general stuff of doing and this is
pretty common Panda's code I think if
you have a messy data set you'll do a
bunch of stuff like a data import time
so reading it into CSV fixing up the
column names this drop in a is getting
rid of the rows like this October month
header so get rid of those rows select
these columns create this new or
whatever overwrite the column date to be
um to be an actual date time using this
weird format uh setting the index
appending date to the index and then
fixing up the index names so this is
pretty idiomatic pandas I think and you
get this data frame which still isn't
tidy but it's at least been cleaned up a
little
bit to actually get the Tidy data set
those Team game pairs we'll use this
melt function which comes from uh
reshaped to one of Hadley's packages um
basically same thing so the way M works
it's I I have to look at the
documentation every time because it does
a lot but it does exactly what we need
in this case so the basic idea is is
idars these are things that you want to
repeat enough times to stay with each
observation so these are like the
metadata which game ID and date we need
to repeat this date enough times to stay
with each of the teams which in this
case is two so we have to repeat that
date
twice uh value vars that's going to be
the things that you're is currently
spread out and you want stacked into a
single row okay so you can't just use
stack here right because that just moves
things from the index down um it it
wouldn't handle this repeating the
metadata that needs to be
repeated so melt does exactly what we
need and now that we have the Tidy data
set we can just answer our question like
without too much
effort um you just need to know like
that pandas has this diff method that
does exactly what we need but I think
this is fairly clear what's going on
we're grouping by team we're taking the
date and then differencing that and then
selecting the days and subtracting one
to get the rest so this part here gives
us the days between two subsequent games
for each team and then subtracting one
so the groupy is nice because then you
don't have to deal with like okay what
if I get to the last game for a team or
the first game for a team groupy handles
that it'll introduce the
nans any questions on that operation
there so we wouldn't have been able to
do that on the original data set at
least not easily it it would have been
really messy um so now we can assign
that operation as this rest variable we
have our rest and if you wanted to get
back to that original data set you can
use something like pivot table so you
can pass in the Tidy data set the value
we're operating on is rest we want these
two index columns to match our original
data frame and then columns you can call
it
variable and then rename things so this
is just going from the Tidy data set
back to our original data set so one
thing that might not be clear is the the
definition of Tidy like your definition
of an observation depends on the
question you're trying to answer so we
had a team level question right what was
each team's uh rest for each game but if
you want to answer questions like um you
know like this is a game level statistic
I need to run that cell this is a game
level statistic
um this plot takes a while sorry so you
can answer Team level questions like
this with our tidy data set so seaborn's
just going through each team plotting
the average rest at home and then the
average rest away for each team you can
also answer game level statistics like
this so what was the difference in rest
for each head-to-head matchup so we have
two data sets now and whether or not
it's tidy depends on our
question
okay stack and unstacked uh whoops
uh go down here um they're just useful
for converting between apis so we saw it
a bit before but um more formally the
rest here is going to be in a long form
so basically you know it's it's all
stacked up into one column with like
labels for each thing over
here um some things like pit. plot
expects wide form data so you know we
can again do like a rolling a 14 week I
guess day rolling average of uh average
rest things like that so it's it's
useful to be able to go between things
that expect long form data and wide form
data since not all apis are designed the
same okay um Okay so we've got 15
minutes left which is maybe enough time
um the rest of this notebook is like a
little project that I'll let you all
work on um I'll be walking around if you
have questions but um basically
examining home team Advantage so you
know using this head-to-head matchup um
you know what are the determinants of
home team Advantage so be fitting a
regression that looks like this if you
haven't used we're we're going to use
stats models um if you haven't used it
I've coded that up so that's fine um you
just have to get the data to the point
where this cell actually
runs and I've kind of laid out how I
would approach that um but you're free
to go your own way do it however you
want so
um take 15 minutes and or I guess maybe
like uh 10 minutes or so so that we can
wrap in the last five minutes but um
take 10 minutes try and work on this see
how far you can get um I think it's a
good little project of re reshaping
manipulating data getting you to where
you need to go and then I'll take five
minutes at the end to run through the
example quick okay questions before we
get to that all on the same
page okay uh and feel free to work
together uh this chat room is extremely
empty but hey that's okay uh if you have
questions you can post them in there uh
yeah go forth and do data and I'll
collect you in about 10 minutes or
so which I think might be enough time
for
some and then that'll be it we will not
get to the last notebook
unfortunately
questions
she
y
e
that
this
s
for
that's
this
yes
e
EX
anybody have success with the first step
calculating the win
percent probably the hardest step
actually
unfortunately similar to what we did
before with the uh with the rest we're
going to use melt but instead of melting
down the dates and the teams we're going
to be melting down the uh whether or not
the home team
won so I need to fill this out or I'm
actually gonna
delete that and load my solution so
melting down the value bars home team
away away team so that's the thing it's
spread out across um and then varame
Homer
away so the thing that changed here is
we also want to attach this home wind so
this is like another bit of metadata
that needs to get
repeated so we have these
games um we need a new column for
whether or not the team in that row is
the team that
won so to get that we need them to be
either the home team and the home team
won or the away team and the home team
lost so figuring out is this the row is
this Row the winner for that game so um
you could do that in a couple ways uh
doing this triple equal equal um is the
correct logic I think
so is the team that won home and then is
the actual home R way equal to home
team so this gives us uh a column with
whether or not the you know the Atlanta
Hawks they lost this first
game Chicago Bulls won it good for them
uh aggregate
that so well do my solution here um
aggate that with this um so this egg we
haven't seen this syntax yet but if you
pass a dictionary of keys are going to
be the output column names and then the
values are going to be the aggregation
function so you can also just pass in
like the regular list sum count mean and
then do a
rename so now we have a data frame where
we have two rows per team right home and
away and then we have the number of
games they played the number of wins
they had and the wi
% um pause to see okay are we on the
right track here is there even a
relationship between uh home team is
there is there a home team Advantage
basically it kind of looks like there is
so there's a positive relationship there
this is plotting whether or not the team
is home or away and then we have the one
line basically for each team and most of
these are positive so Mo most teams do
do better at home so we're we're on the
right track here I think then we can
calculate win percent um I don't
actually
know I did it this way by taking the sum
of the wins divided by the sum of the
games played you probably just do the
average of win percent if they play the
same number home and
away so now we have a win percent per
team this is like a team strength
variable that's what we would throw into
our regression it's really bad that
we're doing that because now we have win
on the left side of the regression and
on the right side but oh well we'll work
with it um so calculating uh yeah
basically setting up our final data
frame for the regression so we have um
taking this win percent and getting it
into the data frame so doing that with
map so DF DOA away team is just going to
be a series of team names win percent is
a series
of uh win percents where the index
labels are the team names and what map
will do is it'll look up okay for
Atlanta Hawks it'll look up uh
what or yeah it'll look up the keys
basically by name and then insert the
value um from this 1
percent so now we have our home and away
win percents uh we can calculate the
difference in points we can calculate
the difference in rest and now we can
finally fit our model and stats models
we'll go ahead and do that this is a
Formula we're fitting home wind as a
function of all these
other strength functions and then rest
and you can interpret your results as
you will so um I don't know what the
determinant so the team strength
definitely does matter but again we're
you know that's because it's on both
sides of the equation so that's kind of
bad but that's okay um rest does maybe
not seem to matter as much at least once
you've controlled for strength so um so
that is that I think are there any
questions before we
break okay
cool well I'll be around uh rest of
conference if you have any questions
definitely let me know uh more than
happy to help out so yeah thank you
appreciate
[Applause]
it